the United States because of the way
it's constructed actually truly
genuinely gives you a chance to succeed
no matter where you came from and what
you look like but what matters is what
you do and how you do it but those what
and how matter enormously you can't just
do the work and not the how but what on
how you do matters and I believe that
passionately I would say to be more
challenging if I'd been in continental
Europe in some ways but that's not the
case in the United States so that's not
as much of an issue in your in fact you
know you do stick out a mile when you
look the way I do and you kind of walk
into a company which is a fortune 50
1,400 company and you've got the set
200,000 people at City who worked for me
you just you've got to get comfortable
with your skin and have a little bit of
confidence in yourself that's compared
to worrying about what the other person
is thinking about you you're gonna get
stared at I walked in today I was
telling you and I was I was walking into
your cafeteria and why the hell is
everybody staring and looking at me and
then I discovered you've put my
photograph in every variable which is
the most embarrassing thing in the world
here and I walk in there's this damn
10th card everywhere I hope God no
wonder they're staring at me so that's
not a good thing but you can use that to
your advantage if you care about talking
to people it's a great conversation
opener I've made friends who've talked
to me about why I look the way I do and
they still the best friends I've had out
of a casual conversation so not in work
life in your personal life yeah it can
be quite interesting thing I mean look
there are times like after 9/11 when
life was very complicated for me and I
lived in New York City at that time and
I'd say the best thing I could describe
it to you as I got shouted at and abused
with verbal abuse no physical abuse
fortunately many times but you know you
find your way through it because you
realize they're only 0.5% of the people
or smaller than that are
doing that the other 99.5% of the people
around you are actually on your side and
they care deeply about what you're
feeling at that time and it's that kind
of if you have that strength you can get
through a lot of stuff when I look I
still get randomly pulled out for
checking at TSA I'm the ultimate random
check guy but you know I said what are
you gonna do you can't you can't find
that he could just take it with you so
personally a lot of things come around
you you know my my boss at City at that
time was boss's boss's boss was sandy
violin he called me the second day after
these issues that opted in New York City
and said to me listen you're not gonna
fly commercially for the next few months
you can have the company plane which I
was not entitled to at that time to go
wherever you've got to go I'm not taking
a chance with you getting caught up in
security at the airports you're not
gonna do that rule one rule 2 you need a
car to bring you back and forth from
home eyes to walk in Manhattan to work
you can have my car and I still walk to
work because dealing with it is more
important than hiding from it and yes I
got the looks and I got the odd comment
but I walked to work and I walked back
and once in a while
my boss is to come to my house and walk
with me to work that's pretty cool
that's leadership and it matters so you
can deal with it it's more of a
challenge in that personal side than at
the work for the work front was never a
problem
you